a ukrainian judge sentences vadim
shishmarin to life in prison the russian
tank commander had admitted to shooting
a civilian riding a bicycle but claimed
he was acting on orders his lawyer says
he will appeal this was the first of
many alleged war crime cases being
pursued by ukraine it's now likely
russia will also try many of the
ukrainian soldiers it has captured too
the specter of war crimes is at the
heart of ukraine's diplomatic drive in
davos at the annual world economic forum
emotional speeches from ukrainian medics
and mayors aimed at the heartstrings of
those who hold the world's purse strings
this war is really a turning point of
history
and it will reshape our political and
our economic landscape in the coming
years your courageous leadership
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
told attendees the death toll from an
airstrike near kiev last week now totals
87 and that dozens of ukrainians are
dying every day in the donbass zielinski
asked for yet more coordinated sanctions
and for all businesses to shun russian
money every day getting up thinking what
are we doing for the world with respect
to that unity
that was the message that really hit
home to me
reminders at davos that while the global
economic impact of this war has hit fuel
it has also critically affected food
before ukraine i was already out there
with the clarion call that we've got a
world food crisis and we're facing the
worst humanitarian crisis since world
war ii so now because of this crisis
we're taking food from the hungry to
give to the starving it's absolutely a
crisis mode the un's world food program
says opening ukraine's ports to export
its grain must be a priority to prevent
a world food crisis from spinning out of
control redmond shannon global news
london